adieu explain the witches aux violences
imovie industries in general abiquo
mimos sexy mais comment est ce que vous
vous expliquer le fait que dans au
cinéma de les méchantes deviennent de
plus en plus on les accepte des
deviennent vraiment les 1/8 des films
très sexy tous les aspects parfois
beaucoup de facettes en elle qui
explique ce que la femme en question et
sa tante et je sens que c'est bien rien
de nouveau là rien de nouveau à tous la
question
j'ai aussi le fils de quinze all in
ce film dans lequel votre fils joe l'âge
d'or
comment ça a été de jouer avec votre
fille et comment ce qu'elle a fait je
veux saluer la qualité était vraiment m
ce petit bijou en tant que personnage je
n'aime pas les en chine et en inde une
fois
non j'en étais là son père et sa mère
pour ces questions oui parmi les
quelques francs seront entendus dans les
extraits qu'on a vu ce matin il ya celle
là vous prononcez le mot n'existe la
haine et la vengeance est ce que c'est
une consultation ce type qui vous
engager à faire ce film et peut-être
même à faire les films que vous faites
c'est notre pays il existe et où
l'existence existe eric van duyse wiley
hausse aux autres acteurs
nous sommes à verser obtient une fille
en maraîchage réponse au wyoming shame
on you fat de fatou linsan
malheureusement il ya vraiment deux
du mage dans les lycées regardez ça sera
facile gorilles et tous ces gens matures
volonté est tellement de l'imaginaire
comme si en politique et de la paix au
nigeria ces moments des choses une
cruauté
donc je pense qu'il ya là un vide nous
tous il ya beaucoup de choses très
pauvre de monter un film parce que c'est
disney il ya toujours un message était
le jour en espèces bon est positif et
nous en force doivent déjà raté
tellement de choses dans notre lion gars
tellement de douleur dans le monde et de
et de mal question de cautionner tout
bon saut view for the most exciting la
question est pour vous de quelle a été
la scène la plus excitante sur
magnifique faire
je ralentis je suis tombé rôle de cinna
d'oise m'évite de me cherche à lui été
le plus gros méfiez vous de grisaille
pour moi c'était vraiment le sahel m
parce que déjà auparavant et de manière
parfaite sa mort et c'est vraiment ce
moment j'ai pas il faut y aller avec
autant de plaisir aussi
mieux vaut donc de choses sur le leur
voire des tentes et des défis en fait
les dessins de lessac des caméos dans
l'équipe de thé c'est aussi de faire
revivre les méchants ici ma les films
antérieurs qu'un personnage de
shakespearien
je voudrais avoir votre opinion là
dessus tout la bête de scène humo visa
mindo parole ne peut jamais
et puis le secteur 9
il va là un peu des deux dans ce film
parce que vraiment je la charge et ayant
joué à l'expérience de nos spas de
l'amour d'avoir ce genre de l'or je
trouve super g s'est rendu le
surveillant se fait que familière pour
parler de thèmes beaucoup plus chic et
bien sûr les affiche toujours une façon
de voir les choses et de recharge aussi
mes enfants dans le roi lion dans le
vert moeurs à les appeler comme ça c'est
beau pour les gars
et c'est à ce riche expérience c'est
vraiment bien pour les enfants parce que
les enfants lorsqu'ils sont tout à fait
capables de restaurer cathartique aussi
coaching est toujours alors voici une
question d'avoir pour les deux qu'est ce
que ça vous fait d'interpréter des
personnages disney aussi emblématique si
connu du grand public ce que c'était
aussi quelque chose auquel vous aviez
pensé peut-être même rêver et pour elle
en particulier qu'est ce que ça fait de
devenir une princesse disney de phobos
avis aux amines chat a collecté ce n'est
qu'après je voulais vraiment c'est
complet des costumes à fait le même
le médiateur soutiennent c'était très
excitant pour moi c'est vraiment le film
elle est vraiment né pour est ce que
vous sentez un sujet parce qu'on vous
dit qu'ils étaient parfaites pour
magnifique et elle était parfaite la
princesse est une chose moi alors je me
suis dit je suis tombé sur les dérivés
l'histoire profonde et je me suis
vraiment identifié j'avais vraiment je
pense que j'ai vraiment aimé les enfants
je leur ai dit j'ai un secret à vous
dire comment il allait réagir
oui c'est le mot coaching
vous semblez en tant qu'actrice faire
des routes qui vous amuse beaucoup et en
tant que réalisatrice des films aux
sujets un peu plus grave un peu plus
sérieux est ce le cas risque calculé ou
pas du tout
c'est une personne que je dois faire un
jour de passer deux ans avec qui ont
quelque chose vraiment de pouvoir en
profiter c'est de comprendre et une de
grandir à travers
c'est une décision est attendue ce jour
en fait c'est parce qu'en fait vous
proposez quoi ce genre de film et quand
on vous propose quelque chose qui
c'était la dernière chose que j'ai faite
c'est de tout le monde en a besoin de
comprendre cette période de l'histoire
et des rations que nous avons
aujourd'hui à cette période je n'aurais
jamais pu être là une femme soldat mais
là je peux réaliser aujourd'hui beaucoup
dernière question la scuola de la croix
aux mines cycling vous avez vous avez
une scène d'être tout à fait
impressionnante quand vous encore vous
volez comblera la barre et la serbie moi
j'adore ce genre de choses fait voler
moi j'adore ça
heureuse je suis vraiment grand c'est
vraiment la liberté ultime qui peuvent
les modalités d'un paquet je veux bien
mais la justice